the clouds are gathering over true blue
tory britain the recent by-election
defeat in cheshire and amisham was an
earthquake in these chilton hills
next door in the seat of buckingham
princess risborough is the heart of
conservative country this seat has been
blue since 1970 but even here the once
faithful are starting to turn against
the prime minister
as a former member of the conservative
party you now want boris johnson to
stand down why
because he's become too embarrassing
and letting the party down and who
replaces him
well either rishi sunak or liz trust
you've been a member of the conservative
party do you want boris johnson to be
touring leader at the next election
no i'd like a change why
he doesn't seem serious enough
do you look around and think there might
be other people better people who could
become
prime minister and do a better job yeah
like who rishi sunak
boris johnson was the overwhelming
choice of the tory party in 2019 to be
leader and won a decisive election
victory months later
but now there's wobbling even in the
truest blue heartlands like this one
an exclusive poll for sky news has found
that a third of the conservative party
has lost confidence in boris johnson one
in three members wanting to stand down
before the next election almost half
think he won't be there then that's why
attention is turning to the alternatives
sky news asked yougov to find out about
the tory membership over a third of them
wanted boris johnson to resign now 59
say he should stay on 46 said rishi
sunak would be a better leader and he's
16 thought he'd be worse and foreign
secretary liz trust is just behind him
39 think she would be a better leader
than the pm 22 percent worse
for granted elected in 2019 the local mp
is no traditional loyalist he's been a
thorn in the pm side on covid and hs2
but he's not ready to give up on the
prime minister
yet
we've had a few very difficult months
the christmas parties the
uh the owen patterson
handling the way that that went through
mistakes will be made so to the one in
three tory members who say
boris johnson shouldn't fight the next
election you say
stick with him if we go into a
three-month six-month leadership contest
right now that's not going to be fixing
things for people who are hurting when
they pay their gas bill
more and more tory members unimpressed
but it would be for mps to decide to try
and oust him now they know the members
are willing to be convinced there might
be other options